[Music]
in its hereditary news home it happens
to every man it's fine
submitted by Caliente Cheetos Cali
anthem in Vail
a new study says you can blame your mom
if your love life sucks
oh I blame my mom for all of my failures
do we blame our moms if our love life is
good to know they never get credit um so
much I'm calling my mother after this
yeah so this study followed about 7,000
people and they were followed for a
minimum of 24 years it was mothers and
their biological children and so they
would ask questions about marriages and
divorces as well as cohabitation and
dissolutions
of non marriage relationships and so
what they found is that mothers pass
both their own problems and the way that
they've dealt with those relationships
to their kids
yup make sense it's so like if so like
if this mother would have multiple
partners in not necessarily marriage it
could even be that just cohabitation
then that would lead the child to end up
having a lot of partners as well because
when they learned
no wonder okay go ahead sorry well you
learn your habits from when you were
kids that make sense Lea yeah and so but
now they have the study that I mean is
it actually hereditary or is it learned
behavior yeah
is it nature-nurture true if I did I
started yeah like that's almost like
like learned behavior from like seeing
that you know then why are we just
blaming the mom no we're just like as
dads are usually around no I think it's
moms leo you're you would like you can
relate to them you know what I mean like
that's a figure a female figure so we're
talking about moms and daughters
specifically we're not talking about
like yeah yeah that's negative let's ask
you to specify daughters they just said
children oh but wait so you spend more
time with your mom I don't think so I
think whoa no [ __ ] is blaming women and
men I just thought take a response yeah
that's really weird yeah I feel like my
father heavily impacted how I grew up
yeah like just two years ago I called
him drunk and I was like why did you
leave like immediately it's like I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm like for real you
should have told me that before 10 years
he said I'm sorry and he told me he's
proud of me like every week always post
my picture so I got now I was like
thanks Don all you feel
yeah but like I mean that's that's a hat
but that's a big part of it too I'm
exactly my dad exactly a me to my mom at
all
yeah I'm my [ __ ] pops I can't relate
to my mom at all or her mentality like
what like I'll look at a listen to the
way I'm like we're talking or
disagreeing or arguing about something
and then I'm like oh my god am i dead
right now yeah did you not get along
with your dad when you're going up yeah
I did it yeah I didn't get load my not
either and now I am him weird did get
along with my dad and I feel like I am
oh so I see you get along with yourself
ways yeah I feel like I'm my dad too I
never grew up with my dad like I've
never spent more than like a few months
with him in a row do you feel like
you're like him at all 100% dude me too
like my dad and I didn't talk for like
years and so like that and then like we
talked on the phone and like I don't we
like laughed at the same [ __ ] up [ __ ]
at the same time and I was like and then
we have the same laugh and I was like
sir this is this is really healing it's
maybe but if we talked to all our
significant others that know our mom and
then they're like [ __ ] no you're exactly
like your mom my significant others knew
make significant others knew my stepmom
whenever I talked to her she was the
shoe like multiple times would pause be
like oh my god you're so your dad it's
really frustrating yeah my mom says that
all the time to me yeah okay mm-hmm well
what if it's also because would've you
know we saw a lot of things our mom did
and we were kind of like and we're like
I'm gonna do the opposite yeah so maybe
genetically we're designed to be like
that I read a thing one time about how
they say like if mothers have stress or
anxiety during a pregnancy because it's
literally like a vibration in your body
when you have anxiety and you can
chancer those physical vibrations to the
child yeah I definitely have anxiety
yeah thanks mom yeah thanks mom
I mean that and then the way you're
treating them when you're taking care of
them is gonna transfer over to cause
like yous need to relax and back off a
little bit because then they feel it too
and then they're gonna be stress and
they're gonna be uptight they're gonna
be like okay they're like witnessing
your behavior everything happens when
you're a baby I learned that therapy
holy [ __ ]
Jesus will have like four years your
first seven years are so vital because
you don't like when you think of the
earliest memory like how far back can
you go three really yeah I know I said
like two three - but it's very few
memory yeah yeah a lot of that is stuff
that you're just mimicking from your mom
and your dad and [ __ ] that you do it's
never really something that you're doing
you're on your own that's true cuz I
didn't notice Isaac being like his own
person until like around 70 yeah yeah
it's weird I never grew up my parents at
all I never had like interaction it was
very like I'll see them for a day a
month or like even after a few years my
dad but I grew up and I'm just like me
and my dad are the same and I said the
weirdest thing in the world what the
[ __ ] happened Joe Joe she said like a
day a month or even a year just pretty
wild though I'll give it to Tom because
with my mom every few months or whatever
for a day there you go yeah I'll be
there for you yeah oh yeah
this study was just like yeah blame your
mom because you inherited all her treats
no yeah all of us disagree with this I
believed it if I heard my mom my mom so
they're saying love life you inherited
the patterns because
yeah and like the way you got pregnant
at 22 and then she got married to my dad
because she was pregnant with me and
then they're still together but like I
didn't get pregnant at 22 and then
married he's gonna be exactly like your
love like your love life like the pocket
pair like maybe it would have been the
same but I maybe not every person
obviously either right so maybe they're
saying like 60% of women tend to follow
the same like it could be not I
appreciate all of my mom's footsteps I
just didn't marry Isaac's dad and stayed
with him for seven years but my mom did
that with my dad but yeah like they
split up and then she ended remarrying
which you know I blame my mother for a
lot of things and here's his article
giving me an open opportunity I blame
I'm still like don't my mom once dumped
a fiance because his kids were too loud
in the morning dang that's pretty smart
though cuz she was gonna get married
into that family that would have been
her life yeah they're only kids for like
a couple years she wasn't about it dude
she wasn't over she wasn't a ride a
bachelor she was bad she was remember a
day wakes up in the morning she's
packing her [ __ ] it's like Linda what's
wrong this [ __ ] out
[Laughter]
it's all [ __ ] day long about listen I
used to not be able to flirt with guys I
was super super shy until I got like a
boyfriend and he was shy so it was like
it worked
you can never talked let's just never
spoke to each other no well no we spoke
we like had our goofiness together cute
anyway um so my my I would ask my mom
like how do i flirt and she would like
for long like she was a flirt like she
would try to teach me how to like just
bat your eyes and you look at him and
then and I could never do that she also
wanted me to date an athlete I have
never dated an athlete my mom was trying
to live vicariously but she's like haha
this guy she will yeah my dad's a
baseball player Oh
but like she would always be like what
if you went into sports medicine and he
just bat your eyes at one of those
athletes admittin and then you start
dating have y'all ever done that like
gone into sports medicine what is that
that's what used to do to she was a
flirt and she would be also it works for
my mom my mom inherited my grandma's
thing I've definitely done the look down
and then look back up I've done that on
purpose before but I was like this is
not my game it's really not I mean I
flirt with Stephen Alan but you know
just be yourself yeah you're pretty
flirty just being yourself yeah I think
a lot of people saying you're really
funny I'm like that's just me like I'm
not trying to flirt with you know you're
just nice and I'm 40 yeah she's really
touchy and that can come off as flirt oh
I am I'm a very affectionate person when
it comes to I'm a I think I'm gonna tell
my only found a recent soul actually
that's one thing I did get for my mom
but not hereditary
she my mom didn't know like my mom had
like a almost full hysterectomy and
wasn't expecting to have a child and
then all of a sudden were like you're
pregnant
a partial history yeah so so like when
they were like your pregnant mom almost
having a dilemma because she wasn't with
my dad she was like well what'll I do
and they were like you have to have the
child like you know like that's welcome
well you're never gonna have a kid
otherwise so she had me and my mom was
just still confused like she didn't know
like this was the spokes it happened and
she was like holy [ __ ] this thing is he
hurt you know so my mom didn't know how
to like be a mom yet so she would just
like hug me like a lot like a lot like
she would just touched me or like rub my
head so now as an adult my lovely were
just touch so like I'm a very like I
don't like to touch people unless I
trust them because I'm like this means
too much to me you know that's the only
thing that I really got from my mom
otherwise we both had trash taste in men
touch you guys I'll touch you all with
no hesitation yeah why but like anybody
thank you I'm like fill out this form
[Laughter]
yeah I'm like I don't know if I want you
to have my love I guess I bust balls is
that flirting oh yeah you just pick on a
wobbly all I do too I just make them
feel like [ __ ] and then they're like oh
man I suck me like Zoe well worthy
competitor and then they bust my balls
and then we bust each other's balls and
like that's how I know you're down badly
that's how I got my last boyfriend he's
like God you were so [ __ ] annoying
[ __ ] you're still annoying I love you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah shut up like that's how I
got my boyfriend's you text about 11
o'clock at night so [ __ ] do that
just hang out yeah I don't know what I
do I don't think I do any there I don't
intentionally do anything yeah it's
really you you don't really notice I
don't really know how are you um I play
around kind of I'm not really a big ball
buster yeah I'll play around but then I
do make a lot more eye contact Oh and
then I'll just like really like just
trying to listen and I'll try to touch
or whatever I learned I heard that if if
you're like in a group of friends and um
someone says something funny the person
that you look at when you're laughing is
like see that I could definitely see
that
so whoever I look at and laugh at is
someone that I want to do it with like
kind of yellow yellow connection like
you kind of like laughing
on them than anybody who's my girl crush
make me laugh real quick
believe me love and then I was seeing
this guy once we were all hanging out
with like all his roommates roommates
girlfriends wobble and I was laughing me
and this roommate kept I look at each
other every time and I was just like oh
[ __ ] this is not good and then I was
just like stop like I had to make me
stop intensely make on weird like it was
weird or [ __ ] huh were you attracted
it's cute but I never saw him as like I
didn't in my yeah you weren't
consciously China yeah but then I
realize that every time we would laugh
we would look at each other and I'm just
like oh that's not good at suck it
that's not good and then I would just
like back off I wonder if that's true
like 100% or if it's like you kind of
have the same humor like you're in a
group and like not everyone was I always
look for tip every time I'm laughing I
try to [ __ ] her true we end up always 12
minutes cuz you just like each other the
most and you guys like we feel the
closest yeah yeah I love it amongst yeah
yeah it's just hard to get you kind of
word I don't want to sit here anymore
dibs on Jeannie yeah I already put
myself at the bottom of the list of that
way I don't get excited
yeah I can't be disappointed can't lose
my excitement can't get me Gio